i'm going to do a couple of more moment
of force problems especially because i
think i might have bungled the
terminology in the previous video
because i kept confusing clockwise with
counterclockwise
this time i'll try to be
more consistent so let me draw my
lever again my seesaw
so that's my seesaw
and
that is my axis of rotation or my
fulcrum or my pivot point whatever you
want to call it and let me
let me throw a bunch of forces on there
so let's say that i have
that is a 10 newton force
and it is at a distance of 10
so
distance is equal to 10
right this the moment arm distance is
10.
let's say that i have a
50 newton force
it's 50 newtons
and it's
moment arm distance
is equal to eight
right
let's say that i have a
five newton force
and its moment arm distance is
i don't know four
so the distance is equal to four that's
enough for that side
and let's say
i have a
i don't know
let's say that i have so let's see i
have that's let me just keep going i'm
gonna randomly
let's say i have a i'm gonna switch
colors actually now i'm gonna keep it
all the same color and then we'll use
colors to differentiate between
clockwise and counterclockwise so i
don't bungle everything up again so
let's say i have a
10 newton force here
and that is and of course these vectors
aren't proportional to actually what i
drew right 50 units would be huge if i
if these were the actual vectors
and let's say that that moment arm
distance is three
we'll do a couple more let's say at a
moment arm distance of
eight
i have a
i don't know let's say i have a
a clockwise force of i don't know
i make up a number 20 newtons
and let's say at a distance of 10 again
so distance is equal to 10 i have my
mystery force it's going to act in the
counterclockwise direction and i want to
know what it needs to be
so
whenever you do any of these moment of
force problems and you know you say well
what does a force need to be in order
for this this seesaw to not rotate you
just say well all the clockwise moments
have to equal out of the
counterclockwise moments so clockwise
clockwise
moments
equal counter clockwise i'll do them in
different colors
equal counterclockwise
moments so what are all the count what
are all the clockwise moments well this
clockwise is this direction right that's
the way a clock goes
so this is clockwise
that is clockwise
i want to go in this direction right and
so this is clockwise so what are all the
clockwise moments it's 10 newtons times
its moment arm distance 10.
so 10 times 10
plus
5 newtons times this are in distance
four plus five times four
plus 20 newtons times its moment arm
distance of eight
plus 20 times eight and that's going to
equal the counterclockwise moments and
so the ones that the leftover ones are
counterclockwise
so we have 50 newtons acting downward
here and that's counterclockwise
and it's at a distance of 8 from the
moment arm so 50 times 8.
let's see we don't have any other
counterclockwise on that side this is
counterclockwise right we have 10
newtons acting in the counterclockwise
direction as
moment arm distance is 3 plus 10 times
3. and we're assuming our mystery force
which is at a distance of 10 is also
counterclockwise
plus
force times 10 and now we simplify
and now i'll just go to a neutral color
because the simplification this is just
math now
100 plus 20
plus 160 is equal to what's 50 times 8
that's what 400
plus 30
plus 10
f what is this 2
50 times 8 right that's 400. okay 100
this is 120 plus 160
is 280
280 right yeah 280 is equal to
430. this is a good example plus f i
just realized subtract 430 from both
sides so what's 430 minus 280.
it's 150 right 100 minus
that's a 330 all right so it's 150 so
it's minus 150
is equal to 10f
so f is equal to minus 15 newtons
in the counterclockwise direction so f
is minus 50 newtons in the
counterclockwise direction or
it means that it is
15 newtons
right we assume that it was in the
counterclockwise direction but when we
did the math we got a minus number so
excuse me
i apologize if i blew out your sneaker
your speakers with that sneeze but
anyway we assumed that it was going in
the counterclockwise direction but when
we did the math we got a negative number
so that means it's actually operating in
the clockwise direction at 15 newtons at
a distance of 10
from the moment arm
hopefully that one was less confusing
than the last one
so let me do another problem these
actually used to confuse me when i first
learned about moments but in some ways
they're the most useful ones so let's
say that i have some type of
let's say i have a table
i'll draw it in wood and it's a wood
table
that's my table
and i have a leg here
i have a leg here
let's say that you know
the the center
the center of mass of the top of the
table is here right it's at the center
and let's say that it has a weight
right it has a weight going down of i
don't know what a what's reasonable
maybe 2 kilogram let's say 20 newtons
let's see it has a weight of 20 newtons
let's say that i place some textbooks on
top of this table
or box just to make the drawing simpler
i didn't want
edit undo
let's say i place a box there
and the box is also let's say the box
weighs i don't know this is like 10
let's say it's like 10 kilograms which
would be about 100 newtons so let's say
it weighs about 100 newtons
newtons so what i want to figure out
what i need to figure out is how much
weight
is being
put onto each of the legs of the table
and this might have not even been
obviously a moment problem but you will
see in a second it really is so how do
we know that well well
both of these legs are supporting the
table right whatever the the table is
exert
exerting downwards the leg is exerting
upwards right so that's that's the
amount of force that each of the um
each of the legs are holding so what we
do is we pick an axis so let's let's
just pick this leg just because it i
don't know i'm picking it arbitrarily
right
let's pick this leg and let's pick an
arbitrary axis of rotation well let's
put pick this as our axis of rotation
and why do i pick that as the axis of
rotation because think of it this way if
this if this leg started pushing more
than it needed to the whole table would
rotate in the counterclockwise direction
or the other way if this leg started to
weaken and started to buckle and
couldn't hold its force the table would
rotate down this way and it would rotate
around the other leg assuming that the
other leg doesn't fail we're assuming
that this leg just you know it's just
going to do its job and it's not going
to move one way or the other but this
leg
that's why we're thinking about it that
way if it was too weak the whole table
would rotate in the clockwise direction
and if it was somehow exerting
extra force which we know a leg can't
but let's see if it was a spring or
something like that then the whole table
would would rotate in the
counterclockwise direction so once we we
set that up we can actually
we can actually
we can actually set this up as a moment
problem so what is the force of the leg
so the the whole table is exerting some
type of
some type of without if this leg wasn't
here the whole table would have a net
clockwise moment right the whole table
would tilt down and fall down like that
so the leg must be exerting a
counterclockwise moment in order to keep
it stationary so the leg must be
exerting a force upward right here
the force of the leg right we know that
we know that from basic physics right
there's some
force coming down here and the leg is is
doing an equal operative force up
upwards so what is that force of the leg
and one thing i should have told you is
all of the distances let's say that this
distance
between
this leg and the book
let's say that that is one meter or the
box
let's say that this distance
let's say between the leg
and the center of mass is two meters and
so this is also two meters
okay so we can now set this up as a
moment problem so remember all of the
clockwise moments have to equal all of
the counterclockwise moments so what are
all of the clockwise moments what are
all of the things that want to make the
table rotate this way
right or
this way
well if that leg the leg is the only
thing keeping it from doing that so
everything else is essentially a
clockwise moment so we have this hundred
newtons
and it is one meter away its moment arm
distance is one so we have so these are
all the clockwise moments 100
times one right it's 100 newtons acting
downwards in the clockwise direction
clockwise moment it's one meter away
plus
we have the center of mass of the top of
the table which is 20 newtons
plus 20 newtons
and that is 2 meters away from our
designated
axis
so 20 times 2.
and you might say oh well but isn't this
leg exerting some force well sure it is
but its distance from the our designated
axis is zero so it's its moment of force
is zero right any if it is exerting a
million pounds or a million newtons um
it's its moment of force or its torque
would be zero because it's at it's it's
moment arm distance is zero so we can
ignore it which makes things simple so
those were the only clockwise moments
and what's the counterclockwise moment
well that's going to be the force
exerted by this leg right that's what's
keeping the whole thing from rotating so
it's the force of the leg
times
its distance from our axis well this is
a total of 4 meters which we said here
times 4 meters
right and so we can just solve
we get 100 plus 40 so we get 140
is equal to the force of the leg times
four
so what's 140 let's see
four goes into 140
third let's see it goes into it
3 30 30
35 times
my math is not so good 4.
is that right 4 times 30 is 120
120 plus 20 right so the force of the
leg is 35 newtons
upwards right so and since this isn't
moving we know that the downward force
right here must be 35 newtons
and so there's a couple of ways we can
think about it
if
if this leg is supporting 35 newtons
right
and we have a total weight here of 120
newtons
right our total weight the weight of the
top of the table plus the bookshelf
that's 120 newtons
so the the balance of this must be being
supported by something or someone so the
balance of it is going to be supported
by this leg
so it's 120 minus
is what oh my phone is ringing up shorts
120 minus 35 is what 120 minus 30 is 90
and then 90 minus 5 is 85 newtons
so
disconcerting when my phone rings i have
trouble focusing
anyway
probably because my phone sounds like a
freight train
anyway so there you go using and this
this type of problem is actually key to
as you can imagine build bridge builders
or furniture manufacturers or
civil engineers who are bridge builders
or architects because you actually have
to figure out well if i design something
a certain way i have to figure out how
much weight each of you know the
supporting structures
will have to support and using this and
as you can imagine why is why is this
one supporting more weight why is this
leg supporting more weight than that leg
well because this book is which is 100
newtons which is a significant amount of
the total weight is
much closer to this leg than it is to
this leg right if we put it to the
center there they would balance and then
if we push it further to the right then
this leg would start bearing more of the
weight
anyway hopefully found that interesting
and hopefully i didn't confuse you and i
will see you in future videos